digamos que camino hacia ti en la calle
y te digo tengo esta función gx que voy
a definir como la integral definida de
19 a x de la raíz cúbica de t
dt y luego te pregunto cuál es la
derivada de g evaluado en 27 pausa este
vídeo y piensa en cómo abordaría hace
eso bueno lo más obvio sería g prima de
x y cambiar de color aquí para tener un
poco de contraste que prima de x va a
ser la derivada con respecto a x de todo
lo que tenemos aquí de todo lo pondré
entre corchetes la integral de 19 x de
raíz cúbica de t dt y puede que tengas
la intención de tomar la anti derivada
aquí evaluar x evaluar 19 encontrar la
diferencia y luego tomar la derivada
podrías hacer eso y luego evaluarlo en
27 pero vamos a ver un atajo podrías
usar el teorema fundamental del cálculo
si estás tomando la derivada con
respecto a x de una función que está
definida por una integral definida como
esta donde nuestro límite superior es x
esto va a ser igual a nuestra función
interna que tenemos aquí en lugar de que
la variable sea t
ahora será x entonces esto será igual a
la raíz cúbica de x y eso nos ahorró
algo de tiempo pero puede ser realmente
útil si es muy difícil tomar la anti
derivada de la función dentro de la
integral si es realmente difícil evaluar
esta integral el teorema fundamental del
cálculo puede ser muy útil y volviendo a
nuestra pregunta original que prima de
27 bueno eso sólo va a ser igual a la
raíz cúbica de 27 que por supuesto es
igual a 3 y hemos terminado